you talk in your book about different
hairstyles your book is called you can't
touch my hair yes you don't like people
just coming up now okay you're welcome
to go at that anytime you like oh my
gosh it's really nice thank you
yeah people go back in time when they uh
you talk about just thirty grand yeah it
staples in the back you talk about
different hair styles and you you try
them out like for example and you and
you talk about sort of the the pros and
cons of different hair styles in the
book for example you talk about the afro
let's take a look at the afro I love the
Afro it's like that's normally how my
hair looks with not the color jumps
normally all dark but I love wearing an
afro it makes me feel like I go back in
time I feel like Frederick Douglass I
feel so important and I'm like I feel
like I deserve an iPhone 7 for free
we're a Frederick Douglass alive today
he would definitely be getting sent a
free iPhone right he's done so much now
what about dreadlocks let's take a look
this is the dreadlocks look and tell us
about that look yeah the dreadlocks it's
like what I'm feeling like really cool
and like very powerful like that's my
look that kind of says I go to Coachella
and tell all the white people to take
Native American headdresses off their
head like I'm very I'm just policing
every one of those guys yeah you know
the weave you talk about the weave yes
let's talk about that listen oh that's
the weave right yeah I just got that
done it was massive that was a very like
Diana Ross moment that I have and I love
having the weave but sometimes I like
I'm new to the weave still have only
been wearing weaves for maybe like three
or four years so I tend to lose them how
do you I don't know just forgive me I
don't understand the process but it can
fall out it can fall in patches or it's
it's it's yes exactly yes so I was
staying at my good friend Jamie Lee her
and her husband's their house and I had
my hair in for a long time I was like
twist and I went up to go to the kitchen
and when I got up one of the the twists
thought my head onto the ground their
dog started eating it
really yeah so her husband was chasing
the dog around the house trying to get
the weave back yeah he got it he was
like do you want to put this back in
your head and I'm like no this is done
this is where this man this doesn't go
back now dog can have it yeah yeah but
it was it felt like a very post-racial
moment like you can lose your weave in
front of a white person and they're like
how can I help and not like what's going
on it's right right yeah there's hope is
what you say yes absolutely that's a
very inspiring story
yeah I'll take solace that your white
friend got the weave away from his dog
and handed it back Yeah right that's
like hey we can do it I got to ask you
you have said because you've said that
you dating white guys is very different
experience from dating black guys and
I'm just curious if you could elaborate
on that yeah so my most recent ex he's
white and white white and it was cool
but it like making out him making out
with him looks like kind of the worst
part of the relationship which was it
okay so I'm gonna explain so basically
what happened we would be making out and
then like when we would stop kissing
like my black lady makeup would be all
over his white face so he just looked
like a coal miner from there
not attractive at all
Wow okay so that's really it's not his
fault right yeah its life its life yeah
yeah yeah all right well you uh never
happened to you
yes it has oh yeah oh yeah yeah it was
me and a black man that's even better
but it's the same thing
yes it's progressive of you yeah
you